Ok,
bonjour euh. Rima, salut
bonjour Rima,
aujourd'hui, on est euh. À ville peinte pour euh.
L'ouverture euh. De la convention de l'Union populaire
pour les élections européennes.
Hum, j'aimerais te demander,
qu'est-ce qui a fait aujourd'hui
de te retrouver sur
cette liste et d'avoir accepté de
rejoindre la France insoumise ?
Moi, j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire,
la politique, c'est 1 question de moment.
Et sur les sujets que je porte, il y a euh,
1 urgence à agir,
tant sur les questions de migration
pour apporter 1 autre narratif
ne peut pas être celui de la haine de l'autre
et du vide politique
qui est porté par le Rassemblement National.
Et sur la question palestinienne, on l'a vu,
il y a 1 génocide qui est en cours,
il y a plusieurs affaires devant les juridictions
internationales qui vont se euh.
Se qui vont avancer
sur les prochains mois et qui sont en procédure.
Et donc on a besoin
de de le porter politiquement et surtout de
d'amener les États euh.
Face à leurs responsabilités sur ces sujets,
et notamment les États européens.
J'ai j'ai 1 question
particulière sur les quartiers populaires.
Mhm. Est-ce que t'aurais 1 message à passer euh.
À l'ensemble des quartiers populaires de France,
mais aussi aux amis noirs,
les inciter aller s'inscrire et aller voter
pour les prochaines séances électorales ?
Oui,
euh. Il faut bien comprendre que y a 1 enjeu pour nous
de mobilisation des personnes qui se sont euh.
Désintéressées de la Politique de manière générale,
mais qui, mais surtout, euh,
y a aussi des élections européennes
qui paraissent parfois lointaines,
qui paraissent lointaines, des enjeux qui paraissent
pas à la hauteur de ce qu'on peut attendre.
Et c'est vrai qu'on peut
légitimement se dire que la priorité,
elle se joue sur le territoire.
Nous, notre rôle,
c'est de rappeler qu'on est interdépendant,
euh, de cette réalité européenne,
que c'est aussi euh, 1 force,
1 richesse, et qu'on peut changer la donne,
notamment avec des politiques qui sont bien pensées,
à 1 engagement qui soit à la hauteur,
comme on essaie de le porter dans cette liste
pour les quartiers populaires, pour. Plus précisément,
il faut,
je crois, qu'on prenne toutes et tous 1 responsabilité,
notamment vis-à-vis de de de ces cartes,
qui consiste aussi à se questionner
sur la raison
pour laquelle
ces personnes ne se ne s'intéressent plus,
euh, aux questions politiques.
Peut-être parce que nous-même,
nous les avons pas suffisamment intégrés,
peut-être parce que nous leur avons pas suffisamment
donné de parole,
de pouvoir d'agir,
et que là, pour les les questions, euh,
pour les les élections,
y a pas juste 1 enjeu de mobilisation,
y a 1 enjeu de réintégration
de toutes ces voix dans l'espace politique
et le nôtre.
Merci beaucoup Rima et bonne compagnie à toi, merci.